I never saw my friend again and this is
that story so it was many years ago and
I was walking my dog and Brooklyn one
night little tiny white Jack Russell
Chihuahua it was very very hot and I
just wanted to go home and I was saying
make poopie make poopie I have no
empirical evidence that this creates
poop but it was what I was doing and
he'd finally proved we were gonna go
back home and if you've ever lived in
New York this summer can be very sultry
and disgusting and I just wanted to get
inside when I see this guy walking
towards us down the street with a little
dog our leash my little dog Charlie gets
very excited like wagging getting down
on the ground the other dogs excited now
I have to talk to this total and
complete stranger about nonsense because
we have two animals at the ends of ropes
that want to send each others butts we
start talking just sort of talking about
the weather and he says oh I was just in
Texas I was like oh I'm from Texas
there's like Oh what part I was like San
Antonio was like I was right neither we
had so much great Mexican food oh I miss
the Mexican food don't you love the
guacamole yeah I love the guacamole they
don't know how to do guacamole here am i
right we're just like going back and
forth it's been like half an hour our
dogs are just sort of like chillin next
to each other like checking out the
block at one point I finally tell him
I'm like hey I live right here why don't
we hang out sometime and he says oh well
there's like a weird pause like I don't
know why he's not saying yes let's do
that he's like well I'm um I'm moving
away soon I said oh oh that's fantastic
where are you going and he says I'm
moving to Belize and I'm like oh my god
you're making your American dream come
true of leaving America good for you and
he says yeah I've been going there scuba
diving for years I love it I'm just
gonna like go there and just float in
the ocean and I'm like that
is amazing earlier he had mentioned that
he lived with his dog and his girlfriend
I was like oh are they gonna go with you
to Belize and he got real quiet again
like I said something really wrong and
he says oh they're not coming with me
I'm kinda like mmm okay this is weird
it's real quiet and then he just blurts
out I have terminal cancer and I only
have six months to live
and I kind of don't like know how to
respond and he can see me
flustered and he immediately starts kind
of like spinning out like he starts
apologizing he explains to me that you
know he's been having to tell family
members and friends this information for
months and people have cried and
screamed and he feels like over and over
again he has to comfort them and he said
it was so nice in this moment to tell
you a total stranger and be ok about it
but he starts to apologize and he's kind
of getting tears in his eyes about it
and I want to calm him down
so finally I just blurt it's ok I'm a
storyteller at which point like the
ghost of myself exits the front of my
body walks around it kicks my own ass
like he just basically confronted me
with his mortality and I was like I have
a hobby
and then I freaked out oh my god I mean
I'm so sorry that you're dying me not
that you're dying me hey hey hey no no
it's ok telling you this my experience
my story what I'm going through was
really wonderful to say this to a
stranger and I honestly think the world
would probably be a much better place if
everyone told each other their stories I
said yeah I agree he stood there for a
minute made some small talk and then he
finally said well I've got to go I said
okay well take care and he open his arms
and he hugged me and then I said goodbye
like goodbye you know returned Hren we
walked opposite directions and literally
I probably wasn't ten seconds away from
him when I burst into tears like and I
remember my little dog being like what
you cuz animals they don't get immense
like sobbing or like what's happening do
you want to play I get upstairs in my
apartment and my boyfriend is there and
he was like Davey what happened and I'm
like well I looked at this guy so we
started talking he's gonna die of cancer
and he's like calm down the next day I
woke up and I couldn't stop thinking
about him I did what you do in you know
the 2000s when you meet someone with a
terminal disease I befriended him on
Facebook and they sent him a little
message I just said hey it was nice
meeting you
and over the next six months I watched
his Facebook page and I literally saw
his experience in Belize just through
images
changed his profile pic and his banner
pic I saw beautiful trees swaying on the
beach I saw these sort of underwater
pictures of this beautiful like Azura
ocean I saw like stingrays starfish and
after about six months the pictures just
stopped updating and I knew what had
more than likely happened as it Kevin
had had passed away now during this time
I had actually been really sick too I
had Crohn's disease and I got down to
like a hundred and seventeen pounds I
had been in a bad place but my life
started to change I was feeling
healthier and I was really really
hitting story-telling heart and I
started teaching storytelling I would
use the story of meeting Kevin as a way
to tell students or people I was
coaching or directing about the
importance of sharing their stories you
know people would be working on stories
about domestic abuse or really personal
loss when they would doubt it I would
often time to share this anecdote about
Kevin it was probably about two
two-and-a-half years after I'd met Kevin
when one day I was on Facebook and you
know Facebook had just didn't that thing
where they redesigned the interface and
it made you feel like a senior citizen
like where am I almost dudes like
banging and stuff and I finally found
this thing I didn't know was there it
was like a sub trash folder under a like
span kevin had sent me a message the
night that we met and all it said was it
was so nice talking to you I'd love to
continue this friendship
here's my number
and I immediately burst into tears I'm
so angry I was so frustrated thinking
how did I like miss this chance to
maintain this friendship and I put
Charlie on a leash and I went for a walk
I was probably halfway down the block
when I saw a neighbor of ours and she
could tell I was upset and she's like
what's wrong and I was like well you
know about two 20 years ago I met this
guy on the street with cancer and some
telling her the story
her face shifts and she says oh are you
talking about Kevin that jerk she tells
me the story of Kevin a man who had
subletted her apartment with his
girlfriend and their dog a couple years
earlier him and his girlfriend were
going to part ways he was gonna go to
police he was gonna get her kind of
settled and that she was gonna go and
move west kevin was gonna put her stuff
in storage anyway he went to police and
when she came to the storage unit and
the apartment it was all empty because
Kevin had sold all of her stuff to feed
his crystal meth addiction Kevin did not
have terminal cancer he was a drug
addict I don't know how he developed
this lie I did find out that I was one
of many people in the neighborhood who
had met Kevin one night and held him
while he cried and they cried maybe he
was so caught up in his addiction and
the lies around it and the money he owed
people and the jobs he lost maybe one
night he just tried it out you know he
just wanted to see what does it like to
say I'm dying someone held him and
hugged him and it felt good and I come
away from this conversation and I'm so
angry and I go upstairs back to the
computer and I sit down and I look and
Kevin has sent me a message on Facebook
and it just said hey what's up I click
on Kevin's profile
Kevin moved back to New York he's a
foodie there's pictures of him like
eating chocolate cheesecake hashtag
yummy I am just like in a rage like the
sadness that I had felt down on the
street talking to this woman became this
kind of like like as I look at this like
who the hell does this guy think he is
but then the thing that really hits me
is like not so much that he betrayed me
but I told the story of him too
people who I was teaching and when I
think about having used this story to do
that I'm just like and I spread this
like figurative cancer ironically do you
know what I mean like I used the story
of this dude to impart the importance of
truth to people and it was just a
flat-out lie it made me think about the
importance of stories and why we tell
them I think meeting Kevin served a
purpose in my life and even though the
story that Kevin told me was a lie
the way that it made me feel wasn't
[Music]